foreign
happy
[Applause]
Friday everybody sit down
Sit no you till it's Friday and you know
what that means let's welcome tonight's
guests her favorite hobby is calling
Andrew Cuomo laughing and then hanging
up Fox News meteorologist Janice Dean
his razors are very popular with the
depressed comedian and founder of
Western Razor Company David Angelo
you know there's no I in team but she
puts three of them in irritating New
York Times best-selling author and Fox
News contributor Kat Tiff
and finally he considers a side of beef
to beef finger food New York Times
best-selling author can comedian former
NWA world champion
I drink too much coffee so my tongue is
really sticky
yeah thanks for sharing yes so before we
get to some news stories let's do this
Greg's leftovers
yeah leftovers where I read the jokes we
didn't use this week and as always it's
my first time reading them so if they
suck we'll throw Joe Mackey to the
wolves and turn his entrails into
Christmas ornaments
all right here we go Kareem Jean-Pierre
is rejecting claims that the White House
staff treats Joe Biden like a baby
in fact she says Joe is reading at a
third grade level
and can walk several steps without
falling down
when asked about a stain on her shirt
she said Joe spit up on her while
burping him
On a related note Kamala Harris says she
quote may have to take over as president
and is ready to do so
and by takeover she means smothered Joe
with a pillow during nap time
oh she looks like the worst real estate
agent
a study shows opposite sex couples have
less in common than previously thought
while other scientists note homosexual
couples have more in common like
genitals foreign
a lot that makes sense yep
in a recent interview a trans sorority
gal named Artemis Langford what is this
the Wild Wild West
discuss the legal wind that allows her
to stay at an all-female sorority known
as Kappa Kappa Gamma the suit alleged
Langford had an undergone feminization
procedures like hormones or getting
surgery or making sandwiches
that didn't work I liked it I thought it
was hilarious I did too I loved it she
looks like she can make a sandwich try
it again sandwiches right fellas yes
but anyway the judge dismissed the case
adding that sorority sisters can no
longer discuss who let the toilets heat
up
that's for Langford she's just glad
she's found a place in the house and as
first string defensive end on the
football team
in a new poll almost half of registered
voters said any Republican would be
better than President Biden prompting
one woman to legally change her name to
n e Republican
the abuse Whoopi Goldberg has contracted
covid for the third time proving once
and for all the virus does not cause
loss of appetite
a bear broke into a Florida family
screen porch and drank three white claws
the first White claw was too cold the
second too warm
but the third one
that joke was for the kids
now go to bed speaking of animals an ice
cream parlor for dogs opened in Virginia
in response millions of Virginia
residents say it's nice to see dogs
licking something besides their balls
the most popular flavors chocolate
vanilla and ass
[Laughter]
Harvard has been named the worst college
in America for free speech the best the
University of go yourself
yeah I'll probably get edit it out so
who cares in a Reddit Forum a woman
complained that her boyfriend slept
with his dying female friend as her
final wish
the boyfriend did promise however that
since his friend died he probably won't
have sex with her again
he said probably probably
he shouldn't have bragged at the funeral
by telling his Bros been there done that
by the way dying women are most of my
conquests after sex with me they know it
can't be topped and see no point in
living
[Applause]
laughs
it's like oh I'm finished buckle up open
the window all right
a gay hookup app called Grindr I've
never heard of this
[Applause]
is reporting that they've lost half
their employees following a return to
office mandates former workers said
showing up in person was a real pain in
the ass
boo all right I think the word was Ill
researchers uh believe artificial
intelligence May one day allow us to
speak to other species and it will also
allow us to talk to inanimate objects
a new study suggests vaping could reduce
sperm counts and lead to a decrease in
testicle size which coincidentally are
the same exact side effects men
experience during The View
[Applause]
23 people were hurt when an SUV crashed
into a Denny's in East Texas the SUV
would have caused more damage but
luckily it was stopped dead in its
tracks by a sticky table
[Applause]
that's the problem
syrup
how can you run a restaurant with syrup
it's the worst thing ever I I'm gonna go
on a limb here Denny's even without
syrup will still be sticky yes
I love their sticky buns but enough
about the waitresses
a Delta Airlines flight was forced to
turn back after a passenger suffered a
case of catastrophic diarrhea the smell
was so bad many passengers thought they
were flying Spirit Air
and finally Fanta is releasing a new
Halloween mystery flavor that turns your
tongue black one taste tester was upset
saying of all the body parts that could
turn black they chose the tongue
[Applause]
understand that joke I do
now to the news so is Jimmy Fallon's
staff crying or is rolling stone lying
Rolling Stones has published a massive
stupid 3700 word hit piece on The
Tonight Show host Jimmy Fallon the
former magazine claims that behind the
scenes The Tonight Show is a toxic work
environment yes apparently Fallon is a
huge a-hole a terror at the office with
a troubled life
but hey working with Janice Dean we can
relate
stop it
you you should have seen what she did to
those kids at the Make-A-Wish dinner
drawing tropical storm fronts on the
backs of their bald heads
anyway
several Anonymous staffers claim Fallon
is a passive aggressive Tyrant with a
suspected drinking problem it's the same
thing they said at The Ellen Show except
she was drinking human blood
so how how bad is it really well one
worker blamed their declining mental and
physical health claiming they suffered
from weekend weekend
nail beds and hair thinning otherwise
known as Jesse Waters syndrome
we also learned that the guests dressing
rooms became known as crying rooms
because that's where staffers would go
when they were so upset
you know we'd have crying rooms here but
my staff is too damn lazy to wait in
line
and it's stupid technically any room can
be a crying room I once made a nun cry
in a laundromat
I told her she had a nasty habit
he makes Mr Rogers look like a serial
killer
but being the frightened helpless goober
that he is Fallon apologized
dude you gotta stop with the apologizing
especially to people who snitch
them
no I'm serious these These are trying to
get you fired and you apologize do what
I do to backstabbing employees I get
them jobs at Colbert
in three weeks they kill themselves
but I do wonder sometimes what am I
doing wrong why isn't my staff bitching
to Rolling Stone about my horrible
workplace Behavior everyone else around
here gets a badass reputation except me
Judge Jeanine for skinning rabbits in
her office Dana for that time she
punched a cop
and of course Shannon bream whenever she
makes her head spin around like the
Exorcist
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else